bienvenidos de vuelta en el último vídeo
les hablé sobre la presión que esta
relación entre la presión por el volumen
es una constante y que se incrementa la
presión o se incrementa el volumen vas a
disminuir la otra de las variables
verdad es decir si tú apachurra es un
globo o una caja no hay agujeros
entonces la presión dentro de la caja
incrementa verdad con esto dicho vamos a
ver si podemos hacer un par de problemas
típicos que quizás veas en algún examen
así que digamos que tenemos una caja o
un globo o lo que sea y tiene un volumen
digamos que el volumen inicial
déjenme quitar todo esto vamos a iniciar
todo entonces digamos que mi volumen
inicial son cincuenta cincuenta metros
cúbicos y que mi presión inicial es de
quinientos pascal es que vamos a
tomarnos 500 pascal es así que si
recuerdan lo que es un pascal esto es
newton por metro metro cúbico verdad eso
es un pascal
vamos vamos a tomar esta caja o este
globo lo que sea y vamos a comprimir lo
a 20 metros cúbicos así que si lo
comprimimos si lo apachurra vamos
digamos como en el ejemplo del vídeo
pasado entonces es el mismo contenedor
pero ahora lo apagamos a 20 metros
cúbicos así que cuál será la nueva
presión bueno inmediatamente deberíamos
tenerla la intuición de que se vuelve
más difícil cada vez de comprimir más
verdad porque estoy disminuyendo el
volumen y por lo tanto la presión está
aumentando en lo cual ya no me permite
apachurrar tanto lo el globo entonces
cuál va a ser la nueva presión en
definitivamente va a ser mucho más
grande sí así que la presión va a subir
vamos a ver si podemos calcular lo
sabemos que la presión inicial por el
volumen inicial es igual a una constante
y además como no tenemos ningún cambio
de energía simplemente estamos
disminuyendo el tamaño de la caja no
estamos diciendo que que hicimos algún
trabajo con nadal es verdad entonces la
misma constante va a ser igual a la
nueva presión
a por el nuevo volumen así que podríamos
tener en general esta relación de 1 x de
1 y 2 por b 2
así que suponiendo que no hay ningún
cambio de energía ni se sale la materia
del sistema digo en la mayoría de los
casos es así para un examen entonces la
presión inicial era 500 pascal es por 50
metros cúbicos una una cosa que hay que
tener en mente es esta equivalencia
verdad porque una vez que elegimos
ciertas ciertas unidades ciertas
unidades para la presión y el volumen
debemos de mantener la verdad por
ejemplo realmente no sabemos quién es
esta constante acá hasta ahorita verdad
pero se cumple esta igualdad siempre y
cuando usemos las mismas unidades tanto
para la presión como para el volumen de
ambos lados verdad podríamos haber hecho
exactamente lo mismo si a lo mejor en
vez de metros cúbicos hubiera yo puesto
litros ok
quién sabe qué unidad pero bueno sólo
para para garantizar que esto se cumpla
debe ser las mismas unidades de ambos
lados en este caso tenemos 500
tales por 50 metros cúbicos y eso debe
ser igual a nuestra nueva presión que no
sabemos hasta ahorita cuál es pero que
multiplica 20 metros cúbicos así que
veamos qué podemos hacer podemos no sé
dividir por 10 a ambos lados quitamos
este perito de por aquí y luego
dividimos ambos lados por 2 eso nos
convierte este en un 250 y al final
tenemos 250 por 5 es igual a pedos
verdad y entonces nuestra presión final
va a ser de 1250 pascal es muy bien sí
eso sí mantuvimos las unidades y demás
entonces si disminuimos el volumen más o
menos como un 60 por ciento entonces
vamos a tener que la presión se aumenta
como dos veces y media verdad eso eso
cuadra con lo que hablamos anteriormente
ahora vamos a agregar otra variable a
esta mezcla digamos vamos a hablar ahora
sobre la temperatura
y justo como la presión y el volumen el
trabajo y muchos conceptos de los que
hablamos en física la temperatura es
algo con lo que estamos razonablemente
familiarizados
entonces tenemos aquí la temperatura
como vemos la temperatura bueno una alta
temperatura significa que algo está
caliente verdad es decir la temperatura
baja te dice que algo es frío entonces
intuitivamente mientras más temperatura
mientras más temperatura esto implicará
que tenemos mucha más energía que el sol
por ejemplo tiene mucha más energía que
un cubo de hielo seguramente verdad y yo
creo que eso es bastante para que
tengamos una idea de qué es lo que
tendríamos en términos de energía verdad
por ejemplo este ejemplo vamos a tomar
esto digamos que tenemos 100 a 100
grados celsius de una taza de té
ok lo que tenemos a 100 grados déjenme
pensar en algo algo una
no sé un barril un barril de tv que sea
exactamente lo mismo para que vean la
equivalencia verdad de lo que están
manteniendo así que aunque están a la
misma temperatura que son 100 grados
celsius de hecho ambos están hirviendo
verdad como el barril tiene mucha más
materia dentro en realidad tiene más
energía es decir está igual de caliente
pero tiene más moléculas ahí adentro
entonces qué es la temperatura
la temperatura en general es una medida
que que es más o menos digamos igual a
una constante por la energía cinética en
la energía cinética promedio
y energía cinética promedio por molécula
bueno vamos a ponerlo así este silo que
por molécula pues dividido entre el
número de moléculas verdad entonces el
promedio del sistema dividido por el
número total de moléculas que tengo o de
otra forma que podría hablar de esto es
esencialmente de la energía por molécula
así que algunas veces vamos a tener un
montón de moléculas aquí está la n así
que una forma de verlo es que la energía
cinética del sistema va a ser igual
al número de moléculas por la
temperatura y como la k es una constante
podemos pasarla dividiendo pero como no
sabemos quién es acá y estamos pasando
por una entrega realmente es cualquier
constante verdad entonces esto sería
igual a una constante por el número de
moléculas
de partículas por la temperatura no
sabemos aún quién es esa constante lo
vamos a ver después así que además
teníamos el vídeo pasado que la presión
por el volumen es igual a una constante
por la energía cinética del sistema ok
si tomamos todas las moléculas y
combinamos su energía cinética bueno
estas estas constantes no son las mismas
déjenme ponerle este cada uno ok
entonces también tenemos que la energía
cinética del sistema por esta expresión
que encontramos abajo es igual a cierta
constante k 2 por el número de moléculas
por por la temperatura verdad por la
temperatura entonces si lo piensan así
puedes decir algo así como que la
presión por el volumen es proporcional a
la a esto y eso es proporcional al
número de moléculas por la temperatura
entonces la presión por el volumen es
proporcional con otra constante digamos
k 3 ya después veremos quiénes son estas
constantes por el número de moléculas
por la temperatura y podemos ver la
temperatura como como la energía por
molécula más o menos no otra forma que
podemos decir esto es que por definición
n que es el número de moléculas vamos a
suponer que es constante entonces
dividimos entre t y tenemos que la
presión por el volumen entre la
temperatura es igual a una constante k 4
porque el número de moléculas se
mantiene igual y esto es algo
interesante verdad porque esta expresión
al agregarle la temperatura
quitar todo esto
y creo que con eso entonces tenemos que
la presión por el volumen por la
temperatura inicial es igual a la
presión por el volumen entre la
temperatura final esto tiene sentido
para ti
qué pasa si tenemos por ejemplo otra
caja y tengo mis partículas
digamos que tengo un montón de
partículas otra vez ahí adentro de esa
cajita están chocando entre ellas como
siempre tiene cierto volumen si en
cierta cantidad de presión entonces qué
pasa si la temperatura aumenta que es lo
que estoy diciendo estoy diciendo que el
promedio de la energía cinética por
molécula es este se está subiendo así
que estas van a estar rebotando más y
más y más y rebotan más contra las
paredes así que la presión aumenta
verdad suponiendo que el volumen se
mantiene constante
si estamos jugando con la misma caja
otra forma de pensarlo es de esta forma
digamos que aumentamos la temperatura
pero que por alguna razón resultó que la
presión que la presión fue constante así
que tuvimos que hacer para que al
rebotar masivo tener más energía que
estuvieran rebotando de forma más
alocada aún así la presión no cambiará
entonces lo que tuvo que pasar fue que
el volumen aumentó así que si mantienes
la presión constante la única forma para
que al aumentar la temperatura se
conserve esta expresión es aumentando el
volumen y espero que esta expresión nos
sirva para resolver problemas típicos